in our time a grave Famine of Peace the
words of Pope Francis in his annual
Christmas blessing urby at orbi to the
city and the World
As We Gather with our loved ones let us
think of families that experience great
difficulty and those struggling in this
time of economic crisis
the pope recalled the scars of conflict
in Syria at a time of heightened
tensions between Israel and the
Palestinians he prayed for Mutual trust
and in Yemen Iran Lebanon Haiti Myanmar
and Afghanistan Pope Francis prayed for
reconciliation and peace special
attention was reserved for Ukraine
he's the only children
may the Lord Inspire us to offer
concrete gestures of solidarity to
assist all those who are suffering and
may He Enlighten the minds of those who
have the power to silence the Thunder of
weapons and put an immediate end to this
senseless War
another seasonal message this time
delivered by a king
I'm standing here in this Exquisite
Chapel of Saint George at Windsor Castle
so close to where my beloved mother the
late Queen is laid to rest with my dear
father
having spent a lifetime as heir to the
throne King Charles III continued one of
his late mother's most popular
traditions in the UK the monarchs
televised Christmas broadcast
he did so to a country troubled by
public sector strikes and a crippling
cost of living my mother's belief in the
power of that light was an essential
part of her faith in God
and at this time of great anxiety and
hardship
be it for those around the world facing
conflict famine or natural disaster
or for those at home finding ways to pay
their bills and keep their families fed
and warm
we see it in the humanity of people
throughout our Nations and the
Commonwealth who so readily respond to
the plight of others
and in a Christmas season uncommonly
marked by hardship and strife who but
Santa himself from his Arctic Grotto to
complete a trio of Christmas appeals
this year my own Christmas wish is for
us all of course
to help those in need giving great love
and empathy
I wish you all peaceful and Merry
Christmas
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera